Here's a mistake a lot of people make.
They think body image is physical.
Most of it is mental.
It's all about what you think about yourself and how you feel about yourself.
My mantra would be, "You are more than enough."
Step one, you're gonna need paper.
Number two, you're gonna need markers.
And number three, most importantly,...
...you're gonna need some mantras that you're gonna say every day.
Mantras are personal.
No one has to understand them but you.
My mantras came from a class but yours can just come from you.
Really, it's about making yourself feel good.
Say your mantras every day at least twice before you leave the house.
I want to get those good thoughts in there,...
...thoughts that you think about yourself before you go out into the world...
...and have everyone else impacting you.
So, take those phrases, write them down,...
...put them up on your bathroom mirror and say them to yourself.
I know it sounds weird, but do it because you will thank me later.
Believe me, it makes a huge difference.